there are probably 10,000 stars for
every grain of sand on earth in the
observable universe we know that there
might be trillions of planets so where
are all the aliens this is the family
paradox if you want to know more about
it watch part 1 here we look at possible
solutions to the Fermi paradox so will
we be destroyed or does a glorious
future await us space travel is hard
although possible it's an enormous
challenge to travel to other stars
massive amounts of material have to be
put into orbit and assembled the journey
of maybe thousands of years needs to be
survived by a population big enough to
start from scratch and the planet might
not be as hospitable as it seemed from
afar it was already extremely hard to
set up a spaceship that could survive
the trip an interstellar invasion might
be impossible to put off also consider
time the universe is very old on earth
there's been life at least 3.6 billion
years intelligent human life for about
250,000 years but only for about a
century have we had the technology to
communicate over great distances there
might have been grand alien empires that
stretched across thousands of systems
and existed for millions of years and we
might just have missed them there might
be grandiose ruins rotting away on
distant worlds 99% of all species on
earth have died out it's easy to argue
that this will be our fate sooner or
later intelligent life may develop
spread over a few systems and die off
over and over again but the Galactic
Civilizations might never meet so maybe
it's a unifying experience for life in
the universe to look at the Stars and
wonder where is everyone but there is no
reason to assume aliens are like us or
that our logic applies to them it might
just be that our means of communication
are extremely primitive and outdated
imagine sitting in a house with a Morse
code
you'd keep sending messages but nobody
would answer and you'd feel pretty
lonely maybe we're still undetectable
for intelligent species and will remain
so until we learn to communicate
properly and even if we met aliens we
might be too different to be able to
communicate with them in a meaningful
way
imagine the smartest squirrel you can no
matter how hard you try you won't be
able to explain our society to it after
all from the squirrels perspective a
tree is all that a sophisticated
intelligence like itself needs to
survive so she learns cutting down whole
forests is madness but we don't destroy
forests because we hate squirrels we
just want the resources the squirrels
wishes and the squirrels survival are of
no concern to us a type 3 civilization
in need of resources may treat us in a
similar way they might just evaporate
our oceans to make collecting whatever
they need easier one of the aliens might
think for a second own tiny little Apes
they build really cute concrete
structures oh well now they're dead
before activating warp speed but if
there is a civilization out there that
wants to eliminate other species it's
full more likely that it will be
motivated by culture rather than by
economics and any way it will be more
effective to automate the process by
constructing the perfect weapon a
self-replicating space probe made from
nano machines they operate on a
molecular level incredibly fast and
deadly with the power to a tech and
dismantle anything in an instant you
only need to give them four instructions
one find a planet with life to
disassemble everything on this planet
into its component parts 3 use the
resources to build new space probes 4
repeat a doomsday machine like this
could render a galaxy sterile in a few
million years but why would you fly
light-years to gather resources or
commit genocide the speed of light is
actually not very fast
if someone could
travel at the speed of light it would
still take 100,000 years to cross the
Milky Way once and you'll probably
travel way slower there might be way
more enjoyable things than destroying
civilizations and building empires an
interesting concept is the matryoshka
brain a mega structure surrounding a
star a computer of such computing power
that an entire species could upload
their consciousness and exist in a
simulated universe potentially one could
experience an eternity of pure ecstasy
without ever being bored or sad a
perfect life if built around at Red
Dwarf this computer could be powered for
up to ten trillion years who would want
to conquer the galaxy or make contact
with other life-forms if this were an
option all these solutions to the Fermi
paradox have one problem we don't know
where the borders of technology are we
could be close to the limit or nowhere
near it and super technology awaits us
granting us immortality transporting us
to other galaxies elevating us to the
level of God's one thing we do have to
acknowledge is that we really don't know
anything shirin's have spent more than
90% of their existence as
hunter-gatherers 500 years ago we
thought we were the center of the
universe 200 years ago we've stopped
using human neighbor as the main source
of energy thirty years ago we had
apocalyptic weapons pointed at each
other because of political disagreements
in the Galactic time scale we are
embryos we've come far but still have a
long way to go the mindset that we
really are the center of the universe is
still strong in humans so it's easy to
make arrogant assumptions about life in
the universe but in the end there's
one way to find out right
hey everybody we finally have our own
subreddit come by for surveys
discussions about future videos
ethic use and stuff like that this video
was made possible by your support on
patreon if you want us to make more
videos and maybe get your own bird
avatar in return check it out